[Music]  it's  been a wonderful mix of anticipation for  six months followed by a  massive relief and a lot of pleasure  it's fantastic you know i mean i started  long time ago when i started projecting  max senate pictures against the wall of  my bedroom and playing music slow and  getting kind of depressed and i'd say  chin up keep going  you know sound an image together is  going to get you through i'm not  expecting anybody to look up to an oscar  winner i'm just i'm really pleased on  the path there's many knocks and blows  and  sometimes you kind of work really hard  for a job and you really hope for a job  and then it doesn't come your way every  time you didn't get a job that you  wanted something better came along and  you have to trust him in your fate in  that way it's worked out for me